[Music]
it can't be easy to keep secrets for a
movie as big
and exciting as avengers 4 but these
actors probably could have tried a
little harder
these are a few of the biggest slip ups
by the leading lights of the mcu
a tiny detail there's been plenty of
speculation that the quantum realm will
come into play in a major way in
avengers 4 and it looks like tom holland
may have confirmed that this is the case
speaking with benedict cumberbatch in a
video released by emergency awesome
holland referenced the quantum realm
specifically when comparing his dialogue
in avengers 4 to cumberbatches
he has to talk about so much quantum
realm
stuff just i just have to talk about
yeah man
that's awesome this is cool unless the
dialogue holland is referring to is
along the lines of
gee i'm relieved we don't have to deal
with any of that dumb quantum realm
stuff
then it's a safe bet the strange place
scott lang is trapped in is going to
hold some importance in the final battle
against thanos
long live the queen while promoting
mission impossible fallout
angela bassett who played t'challa's
mother ramonda in black panther
revealed the screen rant that ramona and
shuri survived thanos's purge at the end
of avengers infinity war
when asked if her character was killed
bassett replied no neither did my
daughter
surely she's a bright girl there in
wakanda the fact that both characters
survived could have a serious impact on
the story of avengers 4
and beyond on the one hand with t'challa
dead
the survival of shuri and ramonda may
help determine who takes the throne on
the other
when last we saw shuri she was trying to
separate the mind stone from vision
without killing him
she didn't succeed but she still might
have gained valuable knowledge which our
heroes could use in the coming battle
against thanos
the women of marvel in an interview with
paper magazine
palm clementife who plays mantis in the
guardians films and
infinity war was asked about the me too
movement and her response may have
unintentionally revealed a team-up
between mantis
captain marvel and okoye she recalled i
remember brie larson coming to me and
deny guerrera on the set of the avengers
she told me about the time's up letter
to sign and i found it really amazing to
have all these women and men too
together and fighting for a better world
mantis may have been one of the victims
of thanos purge at the end of avengers
infinity war but clementif's words would
imply that her death won't be entirely
permanent
and if we're getting a team up between
those three it begs the question of just
where it's happening
have mantis and captain marvel made
their way to earth or is okoye somehow
traveling the stars
reunited since avengers 4 promises to be
robert downey jr's final work in the mcu
fans wouldn't be blamed for assuming
tony stark might not survive to see
pepper potts again
tony was already a top choice for the
avengers infinity war kill list and it's
a good bet the stakes will be raised
even higher for avengers 4.
thanks to gwyneth paltrow's instagram
page however we know tony and pepper
will get to see each other at least one
more time
i'm sorry i'm sorry i don't know tony i
swear to god
here right now
in september 2018 while avengers 4 was
in the middle of reshoots paltrow posted
a photo of her and downey on set the
caption read simply lunchtime
accompanied by hashtag pepperoni a
mashup of pepper and tony
so we may not know whether pepper or
tony will survive avengers 4 but we do
know that their scene in infinity war
wasn't the last time the pair would see
each other
the good old days the same day gwyneth
paltrow posted her pepperoni shot on
instagram
chris evans posted a selfie on twitter
unveiling a relatively minor spoiler to
eagle-eyed fans
but one that could point to a much
larger reveal
in the photo evans infinity war facial
hair is gone and his hair more closely
resembles the look we've seen in earlier
films
the shot's caption reads senior year and
is followed by hashtag
a4 as thor correctly pointed out during
infinity war's battle of wakanda
the star-spangled avenger assumed a much
scruffier look in infinity war
okay notice you've copied my beard
now this photo could simply mean that by
the end of avengers 4 steve rogers will
decide he's not keen on beards anymore
however the idea that the avengers will
be bouncing around time
is one of the more heavily trafficked
theories about avengers 4.
evans could easily have been involved in
reshoots for a scene involving a captain
america from another era
in particular the photo gives credence
to a fan theory that was already growing
in popularity
that captain america will not die in
avengers 4 but will instead be sent back
in time to live the life with peggy
carter that his long sleep in the ice
stole from him
if true it could be a beautiful end to
the character's story